for Ukraine to damage the bridge is only
not like a military point but also a
political and psychological to show
Russia that are they are capable of
doing it and also to give some pressure
for Russian population in Crimea because
right now for they can flee the
peninsula only on ferry but when the
weather is windy the fairies don't go so
the only options is through the occupied
Mainland and it's very dangerous because
there is like an ongoing fighting and
in Ukraine there are a lot of dogs that
when the question comes to the
liberation of Crimea that Ukrainian Army
we just destroyed the Carriage Bridge
and be waiting in the entrance of Crimea
because Russian army will have nowhere
to go